hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ztf heute
live sie haben den gesamten Sommer und
Herbst heftig gekämpft und jetzt mit dem
Winter kam nicht nur Schnee und
eisstürme in den letzten Tagen sondern
auch eine patsituation zwischen den
ukrainischen und russischen Truppen das
heißt natürlich nicht dass die Ukraine
jeden Tag weiter angegriffen bedroht und
beschossen wird es heißt aber sicher
dass jeden Tag Soldaten sterben und sich
das Material abnutzt weil weitergekämpft
wird doch es werden keine großen
Geländegewinne mehr erzielt das ist der
Unterschied und wir sehen jetzt auch
gerade die Bilder denn ganz aktuell wird
heftigst gekämpft die ukrainischen
Soldaten verteidigen seit Wochen
erbittert die Industriestadt avdivka im
Osten der Ukraine die Verlusten Verluste
auf beiden Seiten sind massiv und
während die ukrainischen Soldaten seit
bald 2 Jahren ausschließlich diese
Bilder vor Augen haben in an der Front
Linie und wenn sie im Kampf sind so muss
der NATO Generalsekretär hier ein wenig
weiter bei uns im Westen tatsächlich
dazu aufrufen den Krieg in der Ukraine
nicht aus den Augen zu verlieren
Stoltenberg äußerte sich im Rahmen des
nato-ukrainerats wo sich die
natoaußenminister mit dem ukrainischen
Außenminister Kollegen klebber getroffen
haben um eben über weitere Hilfen für
die Ukraine zu sprechen und die Frage
heute bei uns lautet glaubt die NATO
noch an einen Sieg der Ukraine dazu
wollen wir heute live sprechen könnt
Fragen stellen im Stream oder auch per
Mail wir werden unter anderem in dieser
Sendung mit CDU Außenpolitiker Roderich
Kiesewetter sprechen aber zuerst schauen
wir gemeinsam in eine Zusammenfassung
dieses natoreffens von Ulf
Röller herzliche Begrüßung des
ukrainischen Außenministers die Gesten
sind eindeutig bei der NATO aber die
Militärallianz ist besorgt denn der
Stellungskrieg fordert hohe
Verluste wir sollten Russland nicht
unterschätzen wir müen uns auf neue
Luftangriffe einstellen deshalb ist es
wichtig der Ukraine unsere Solidarität
nicht nur mit Worten sondern auch mit
Taten zu
beweisen eine Warnung denn in Wahrheit
wirkt das festliche Bündnis kriegsmüde
vor allem der innenpolitische Streit in
den USA droht weitere Militärhilfen zu
blockieren die Ukraine hat niemand
gebeten auch nicht die USA Soldaten zu
schicken das unterscheidet uns von
anderen unser Angebot ist doch sehr fair
ihr schickt uns die Waffen wir
kämpfen der Ukraine droht ein Engpass
bei der Munition von zugesagten 1
Million
Artilleriegranaten haben die
Bündnispartner bislang wohl erst rund
300 000 geliefert die Ukraine braucht
mehr Waffen Deutschland hat damit
bereits intensiv begonnen durch weitere
Lieferung von Patriots durch weitere
Lieferung auch von zivilen
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen wie Generatoren
und ich rufe erneut weltweit dazu auf
alles dafür zu tun gemeinsam für die
Ukraine diesen winterschutzschirm zu
spannen der Ukraine steht ein schwerer
Winter bevor jeder im Bündnis weiß nur
mit Hilfe kann sie ihn
durchstehen wir schalten jetzt zuerst zu
unseren Korrespondenten florian neuhahn
ist für uns in Brüssel hat das NATO
Außenministertreffen dieses nato-ukraine
Rats begleitet be uns ist außerdem
kevisson jetzt nicht in Washington wie
sonst sondern live zugeschaltet aus
Alaska wo er gerade auf einer
atomfrühwarnstation der USA und der NATO
gedreht hat schön dass ihr beide da seid
hallo hallo hallo nach Deutschland
Florian fangen wir an mit dem Treffen
zwischen den natoaußenministern kouleber
hat heute in Brüssel dementiert dass es
ein Pat gebe ich habe es am Anfang der
Sendung angesprochen obwohl das sein
Generalstabschef genauso benannt hat
kouber sagte sein landkämpfe nicht nur
für sich sondern für euch und meint
damit eben die Nato hat kouleber der
ukrainische Außenminister denn das
Gefühl die Ukraine bekommt für diesen
Kampf aktuell genug Unterstützung von
der NATO na ich würde sagen öffentlich
war Kleber heute diplomatisch und
zurückhaltend also hat sich nicht
beschwert aktiv er hat den Deal wie er
ihn genannt hat wir haben es i auch
gerade im Beitrag gehört so formuliert
ihr liefert uns die Waffen und wir
kämpfen für euch und wenn das der Deal
sein sollte den auch die natostaaten so
unterschreiben dann kann man sich schon
fragen ob denn dieser Deal auch
eingehalten erfüllt wird ob die
Waffenlieferungen ausreichend sind und
da macht man hier schon einige
Fragezeichen dran die meisten tun das
hinter den verschlossenen Türen es gab
aber auch Stimmen die das heute vor den
Kameras getan haben besonders
bemerkenswert war die finnische
Außenministerin Elina walltönen die
gesagt hat nein das aktuelle Maß an
Hilfe des Westens für die Ukraine das
reiche eben nicht aus und damit hat sie
eben aus formuliert was andere eben nur
sich hinter verschlossenen Türen trauen
zu sagen und jetzt ist die große Frage
hat der Westen noch mehr Kraft der
Ukraine weitere Waffen zu liefern die
eben auch die Ukraine zu einem Sieg oder
einem weiteren Vordringen in Russisch
besetzte Gebiete
verhelfen oder reicht diese Kraft eben
nicht mehr ist am Ende die
Kriegsmüdigkeit des Westens zu groß und
dieses Wort diese Debatte hat die Tage
hier in Brüssel bestimmt wir haben viele
rhetorische
Versicherungen gehört dass es keine
kriegsmütigkeit gibt aber die Zweifel
die sind doch würde ich sagen relativ
groß und vielleicht gibt's ja auch
Zweifel weil das Hilfspaket das
ukrainehilfspaket dass der US-Präsident
zuletzt vorgeschlagen hat immer noch
nicht durch den Kongress ist schwächelt
die Hilfe aus den USA
immer also er will ja über 60 Milliarden
zusätzlich für die Ukraine eigentlich
bekommen vom Kongress das Problem ist
dass es im Kongress von den
Republikanern verknüpft wird mit
innenpolitischen Forderungen das heißt
es gibt ganz scharfe Forderungen an den
Präsidenten er soll die Zuwanderung zu
den USA an der Südgrenze massiv
einschränken und begrenzen auch
rechtlich Vorgehen gegen die illegalen
Einwanderer dort und nur dann würde er
das Go das grüne Licht bekommen von den
Republikanern im Repräsentantenhaus um
eben auch die Hilfe für die Ukraine zu
bekommen und ist es so dass innerhalb
der republikanischen Partei eigentlich
unter den Senatoren und Repräsentanten
mehr also eine deutliche Mehrheit
eigentlich sogar für eine weitere
Unterstützung der Ukraine ist aber wenn
der Präsident nicht noch Zugeständnisse
macht in der Politik bei dieser
Zuwanderung dann wird es eng es sind
noch einige hundert Millionen Dollar zur
Verfügung bis zum Jahresende würde das
reichen mit Sicherheit hören wir aus dem
Pentagon und der amerikanische
Außenminister hat ja heute bei dem
Treffen ganz klar gesagt wir stehen
weiter an der Seite der Ukraine und
geben ihr alles was sie braucht man
solle bitteschön auf das große Bild
schauen und das zeigt doch dass man
schon ein ganzes Stück vorangekommen ist
auch wenn es jetzt im Winter Tag für Tag
natürlich in den nächsten Wochen und
Monaten sehr sehr schwierig schwierig
auch deshalb wahrscheinlich weil die EU
hatte eigentlich versprochen binnen
eines Jahres eine Million an Geschosse
zu liefern wird dieses Ziel weit
verfehlen verspricht die EU und die NATO
Dinge Florian die sie am Ende nicht
halten
kann in dem Fall war es eindeutig die
Europäische Union die deutlich zu viel
versprochen hat im März letzten diesen
Jahres hatte man gesagt bin einen Jahres
eine Million an dringend benötigten
geschossen zu liefern aktuell du hast es
gesagt steht man bei
300.000 vermutlich wird man so bei einer
halben Million landen also eine
deutliche Verfehlung dieses Ziels jetzt
muss man sagen dass schon im März viele
Zweifel hatten ob das Ziel wirklich
realistisch sei auch der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister pisturius hatte
diese Zweifel geäußert aber er hat eben
mit zugestimmt auch Deutschland hat
dieses Ziel beschlossen und damit der
Ukraine diese Hilfe versprochen das ist
jetzt eine ziemliche Blamage muss man
sagen gerade eben für den europäischen
Teil für die Europäische Union im Rahmen
auch der NATO und es steht eben würde
ich sagen für einen für ein größeres
Problem für eine eine wachsende Kluft
zwischen dieser
unterstützungsretorik und der
unterstützungsrealität des Westens es
fehlt der Ukraine ja an viele nicht nur
an Munition auch an Flugabwehrsystem aus
dem Westen oder auch möglicherweise an
weiteren Waffengattungen wir denken an
die berühmte Diskussion jetzt die seit
Wochen geführt wird über die Taurus
mauschflugkörper die der Deutschland
eben hätte aber nicht liefern möchte
insofern es ist hier tatsächlich die
Frage erfüllt der Westen erfüllt Europa
das was es da versprochen hat und es
gibt daran berechtigte Zweifel Olaf
sherdin kommentiert bei uns bei Youtube
im Stream es ist Zeit dass Europa sich
klar darüber wird ob es ein Sieg der
Ukraine will wenn ja müssen jetzt die
Weichen gestellt werden und massiv
Rüstungsgüter und Munition gekauft
werden auch für die Ukraine kommen wir
noch auf eine interessante Sache zu
sprechen hat sich der
Verteidigungsminister nämlich heute dazu
geäußert der deutsche und zwar geht es
um einen Bericht der Bild die Bild die
will wissen dass ich Bundeskanzler
Scholz und US-Präsident beiden darüber
abstimmen die Ukraine nur noch no s weit
zu unterstützen um sie zu einer
Verhandlungsbereitschaft mit Putin zu
bewegen heißt es da Pistorius hat sich
heute dazu geäußert nannte das abwegigen
Unsinn zynische Unterstellung die
Ukraine Ukraine in eine Situation zu
bringen die sie nicht will gibt es Elma
irgendwelche Anzeichen für so einen Plan
innerhalb der
US-Regierung nein die gibt es überhaupt
nicht und hier in Washington wenn man
sich umhört hört man eigentlich immer
wieder dass ganz offenbar da deutsches
Wunschdenken eine Rolle spielt
jedenfalls in der deutschen
Öffentlichkeit dass dieser gemeine
gastige Krieg doch mal endlich zu Ende
sein sollte und Ukraine auch bereit sein
müsste dafür territitorium abzugeben
hier hören wir nicht nur öffentlich
sondern auch in Hintergrundgesprächen
sehr klar und eindeutig von der beiden
Administration dass man alles tun wird
und derzeit auch alles tut inklusive der
Lieferung von weitreichenden Raketen wie
die attackems und Streumunition um eben
die Frontlinie aufzuweichen damit man im
nächsten Frühjahr weiterhin vorankommt
man will in eine Situation kommen dass
die Ukraine so viel Druck erzeugen kann
durch weitere Geländegewinne durch das
Abschneiden der Nachschubwege für die
Krim und für die russischen Truppen im
Osten der Ukraine um auf diese Weise am
Ende vielleicht doch auch bei Putin ein
Abgehen von den Maximalforderungen zu
erreichen solange gibt es
hundertprozentige Unterstützung und wir
hören auch eine wilde Entschlossenheit
in der beiden Administration selbst wenn
der Kongress nicht zustimmen würde
weiteren Hilfen hat der Präsident
Möglichkeiten z.B dem er Gelder umwidmet
weiterhin für milliardenunterstützung
und Waffenlieferungen auch zu sorgen und
man muss das Verstehen vor dem
Hintergrund dass die gesamte Weltpolitik
der beiden Administration aufgebaut ist
auf diesem narrativ hier steht die
liberale Demokratie gegen den
Autoritarismus insofern würde diese
Weltpolitik zusammenbrechen wenn man der
Ukraine gewissermaßen in den Rücken
viele und Verhandlungen mit Moskau
vorantreiben wollte und aufgeben ein
Stück des Territoriums der Ukraine also
vor dem Hintergrund glaube ich solange
Joe Biden im Amt ist als US-Präsident
muss man fest davon ausgehen dass die
USA weiter Geld und Waffen zur Verfügung
stellen für diesen Kampf der Ukraine
Florian ich möchte gerne Frage aus dem
Stream an Dich stellen die kommt von
Chris Wats bei Youtube und er fragt wir
bewerten die natoitglieder die
Lieferungen der letzten Monate sieht man
in den Panzerlieferungen eine gute
Strategie in der
Retroperspektive ja natürlich werden
diese Lieferungen positiv gewertet der
NATO Generalsekretär hat hier mehrfach
den Mitgliedsstaaten gedankt für die
Lieferungen von Panzern von
flugabwehrsystemen von Munition also
natürlich das ist etwas was im Sinne der
NATO ist die Frage ist eben es ist
ausreichend und da hat eben auch der
NATO Generalsekretär Jens Stoltenberg
Zweifel geäußert die deutsche
Außenministerin Annalena berbock sprach
hier noch mal davon dass sie sich an den
winterabwehrschirmwünsche für die
Ukraine sie rufe alle Staaten auf dazu
beizutragen denn die große Gefahr f die
jetzt da ist dass wieder Russland das
wieder Putins Armee den Winter als Waffe
nutzen wird indem man z.B Energie
Infrastruktur angreift und damit auch
dazu dazu dafür sorgt dass es zu
Stromausfällen kommt und dass viele
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer im Winter
frieren werden müssen also diese
gefahren werden ziemlich real sein man
hat es ja auch bereits im letzten Jahr
genauso erlebt und jetzt ist die
Frage kann man noch mal rechnen mit
einer Gegenoffensive im nächsten
Frühjahr und da wiederum sind hier doch
viele relativ skeptisch ob das noch
gelingen wird anders als es gerade von
Elm beschrieben ist höre ich da viel
Skepsis aus den Hintergrundgesprächen
hier in Brüssel im Rahmen der NATO und
die große Frage aber wird sein ist
dieser Krieg denn zu einem schnellen
Ende zu führen und alle hier gehen davon
aus dass Russland diesen Krieg
weiterführen wird mindestens bis zur
Wahl in den USA im nächsten November
weil Putin darauf hoffen dürfte dass
dann womöglich ein anderer US-Präsident
im Weißen Haus Platz nehmen wird es
passt zum Schluss aus dem Stream noch
gut die Frage an dich Elma von Thomas
gralz er fragt sich warum übt die USA
nicht mehr Druck auf Deutschland aus
bezüglich
Taurus ja ich glaube man hat einerseits
Verständnis für Deutschland dass das
nicht ganz einfach ist aber andererseits
macht man hinter hinter den Kulissen
Deutschland sehr klar jetzt gilt make or
break das heißt also tatsächlich bis zum
Wahltermin im nächsten Jahr wo sich
entscheidet ob Joe Biden oder
möglicherweise Donald Trump im weißen
haussit dann für das übernächste Jahr
muss man eigentlich alles tun um die
Ukraine in eine Situation zu versetzen
dass sie diesen Krieg mit Verhandlungen
vielleicht auch beenden könnte die USA
haben ein schupfloch sich gelassen die
beiden Administrationen dass sie sagt am
Ende ist die Ukraine der entscheidende
in diesem Spiel das heißt wenn die
Ukraine selber entscheidet wenn selenski
merkt dass die Unterstützung in der
eigenen Bevölkerung für diesen Krieg
wegbröckeln sollte und die Ukraine dann
eben bereit wäre zu verhandeln und auch
Territorium abzugeben dann wären die USA
bereit natürlich das zu unterstützen
aber solange sie das nicht tut noch
einmal kommt Joe Biden nicht daraus aus
dem was er postuliert es ist eine
weltpolitische Frage Amerika würde alle
Glaubwürdigkeit verlieren wenn es der
Ukraine in den Rücken fällt und deswegen
glaube ich dass hinter den Kulissen eine
Menge Druck ausgeübt wird auch auf die
Partner in Europa um Ihnen klar
zuumachchen jetzt gilt's in diesem Jahr
2024 Einschätzung von Elma tiissen live
aus den USA und Florian neuhan für uns
live in Brüssel vielen
Dank und schauen wir uns jetzt mal paar
Fakten an Zahlen dazu deutschland ist
nach den USA der zweitgrößte
Waffenlieferant für die Ukraine und wir
wollen also jetzt mal gemeinsam auf
einen Überblick über diese deutschen
Milliardenhilfen schauen den hat Ksten
heckes für
uns die Liste deutscher Militärhilfen an
die Ukraine ist lang so wurde erst
kürzlich ein zterminen Räumpanzer
wiesind 1 geliefert 2000 Schüsse
Artilleriemunition und 20 weitere m
Schützenpanzer insgesamt 80 wie
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius
ankündigte sollen zu den drei bereits
gelieferten flugabwehrsystemen IRS bis
2025 noch neun weitere
hinzukommen weiterhin nicht auf dieser
Liste zu finden sind die schon lange
geforderten Taurus
Marschflugkörper grundsätzlich stehen
deuts Ukrain Hilfen nicht zur
Disposition trotz Haushaltskrise gerade
erst hat die Bundesregierung angekündigt
die Unterstützung für Kiev im kommenden
Jahr von 4 auf 8 Milliarden Euro zu
verdoppeln bei uns ist nun wie am Anfang
schon angekündigt der CDU Außenpolitiker
und Oberst ad Roderich Kiesewetter hallo
hallo Frau jung grüße sie schön dass Sie
bei uns sind sie setzen sich schon lange
für mehr Unterstützung für die Ukraine
ein sie haben jetzt vor dem NATO
Außenministertreffen auch dazu
aufgerufen die ukrainehilfen deutlich
auszuweiten wir haben im Beitrag gerade
gehört dass Deutschland also in einer
Haushaltskrise ist das wussten wir auch
schon vorher massiv Probleme hat Geld
eben für diverse Projekte aufzubringen
doch der Topf das haben wir im Beitrag
gelernt für die Ukraine der bleibt
unangetastet und sie sagen sie wollen
die Hilfen sogar noch ausweiten da kann
man doch jetzt aber nicht von geringer
Unterstützung von Seiten Deutschlands
sprechen oder nun ein Großteil unserer
Unterstützung Frau jung fast
65% ist die Unterstützung ukrainischer
flüchtl in Deutschland und gerade mal
15% unserer Unterstützung ist
militärische Unterstützung das sind noch
nicht mal 4 Milliarden Euro an Waffen
die geliefert wurden und dazu vorrangig
Flugabwehrsysteme zum Schutz der Städte
aber nur sehr wenig für die kämpfende
Truppe vor Ort sie haben es ja selbst
angesprochen vier Raketenwerfer 14
panzerhaauitzen 18 Kampfpanzer und 80
Marder auf einer Länge von Flensburg bis
Mailand und ähnlich sind die
Unterstützungen unserer Nachbarstaaten
das heißt wenn wir sagen wir sind der
zweitgrößte Unterstützer der Ukraine
liegt das vorrangig an der sozialen
Unterstützung der Flüchtlinge in
Deutschland und je mehr Flüchtlinge
kommen umso größer unsere Unterstützung
gut ist aber dass der
Verteidigungsminister sehr klar deutlich
macht dass es hier nicht um einen Krieg
Russland gegen die Ukraine geht sondern
dass wir alle gefordert sind deswegen
hat er auch deutlich gemacht dass die
Bundeswehr kriegsfähig werden muss falls
oder kriegstauglich falls der Krieg sich
ausweitet was absehbar ist wenn die
Ukraine zerfallen sollte hab den
Verteidigungs Minister gerade
angesprochen er hat sich geäußert heute
zu diversen Themen wir haben auch eben
gerade etwas schon davon angesprochen
eine Sache möchte ich auch gerne
aufgreifen also wir haben über diesen
bildartikel schon eben mit den beiden
Korrespondenten gesprochen diese
sogenannten Geheimpläne von Biden und
Scholz und dort in diesem Artikel wurden
auch sie zitiert mit folgendem Satz man
liefert bewusst nicht das was die
Ukraine zur Befreiung von besetzten
Territorium braucht wie Taurus oder
weitere Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 sondern
beschränkt sich auf die Verteidigung
einer Rumpf Ukraine wenn sie sagen
bewusst damit unterstellen sie ja auch
der Bundesregierung einen konkreten Plan
was wiederum der Verteidigungsminister
abwegigen Unsinn nennt ich unterstelle
das nicht nur ich kann es auch belegen
entscheidend ist dass in der
Bundesregierung uneinigkeit herrscht der
Verteidigungsminister sagt ähnlich wie
die Außenministerin dass die Ukraine
gewinnen muss der Bundeskanzler sagt die
Ukraine darf nicht verlieren aber
Russland darf auch nicht gewinnen das
ruft nach
Waffenstillstandslinie und wir hören und
sehen sehenden Auges wie Russland
Versorgungslinien auf die Krim baut über
80% der russischen militärunterstützung
läuft nun mal über die Krim und wenn man
die Krim von den Versorgungslinien
abschneiden würde müssten die russischen
Truppen über kurz oder lang dort
aufgeben und die einzigen westlichen
Waffensysteme die dies könnten wären die
Taurus weil sie eine Reichweite haben
die an die russischen Eisenbahnlinien
aber auch an die kerzchbrücke kommen und
das Verteidigungsministerium war dafür
liberale Grüne sind dafür das
Außenministerium möchte es aber das
Kanzleramt verhindert es und das ist
genau das was sie eben auch Ansprachen
die Amerikaner erwarten den Punkt mehr
den Elm tevissen ansprach oder auch was
Herr Scherding vorhin im Netz sagte wir
sind uns über die Kriegsziele nicht im
klaren und ich glaube wir müssen sehr
deutlich machen Russland muss verlieren
lernen das heißt das Existenzrecht der
Nachbarn anerkennen keiner will Russland
militärisch schlagen aber Sie müssen das
Existenzrecht der Nachbarn anerkennen
und die Ukraine muss ihre Grenzen von 91
wiederherstellen sonst wird das
russische Vorgehen zur Blaupause bei
Serbien gegen über Kosovo Iran Irak oder
das große Bild der Allianz von China
Russland Nordkorea Iran das ist nämlich
das Taiwan dann von China einverleibt
wird also die Stärke des Westens die
Ukraine in ihren Grenzen von 91 zu
erhalten wird auch daran gemessen ob es
uns gelingt oder ob das Recht des
Stärkeren sich durchsetzt gegen die
Stärke des Rechts dazu passt eine Frage
bei uns im Stream die ich gesehen habe
und da heißt es die Frage ist doch was
ist Sieg in diesem Konflikt dass
Russland aus der Ukraine ein schließlich
Krim vertrieben wird sich Putin
öffentlich entschuldigt und
Reparationszahlungen fließen was glauben
Sie nun in jedem Fall geht es darum dass
die Ukraine ihre Grenzen von 91
wiederherstellen kann dazu gehört die
Krim und dazu gehört der Donbass
selenski war ja bereit zu verhandeln vor
den furchtbaren Kriegsverbrechen bis in
den März hinein hat er Angeboten auf die
Krim zu verzichten auf die
natomitgliedschaft zu verzichten hat um
Reparationen gebeten aber eben auch um
EU-Mitgliedschaft und mit den
furchtbaren Kriegsverbrechen und der
Aussage Russlands wir haben die Zeit ihr
habt die Uhr und eure Uhr läuft ab war
klar dass Russland gar nicht verhandeln
will und Russland hat ja im Vorfeld des
Krieges deutlich gemacht dass es ihnen
darum geht die alte Sowjetunion zu
restaurieren indem die baltischen
Staaten kein Recht haben in der NATO und
in der EU zu sein und dass die Ukraine
wie Weißrussland belaruss kein
Existenzrecht außerhalb der
russländischen Föderation haben diese
Ziele hat Russland nicht aufgegeben und
deshalb ist ein Sieg der Ukraine ein
Sieg des Rechts und es geht eben darum
dass dann wir auch in Kauf nehmen dass
das russische System sich neu orientiert
klar und wenn die Krim fällt ist Putins
Schicksal im Grunde besiegelt wir haben
ja gesehen wie er auf Druck reagiert als
prigosin auf dem Marsch nach Moskau war
dann hat er ein Verhandler eingeschaltet
lukasenko und dann hat prigosin sein
Vorgehen deutlich reduziert aber auch
sein Leben verloren also Putin muss
unter Druck geraten und das geschieht
wenn die russischen Truppen auf der Krim
aufgeben müssen keiner will sie
umbringen gehen wir noch mal ganz
konkret auf die Waffenlieferung auf die
Situation an der Front ein ich habe es
angesprochen der Verteidigungsminister
der hat sich heute auch zu dem Thema
tauruslieferung aus Deutschland auf eine
Journalistenfrage geäußert die auch sie
immer wieder fordern wir hören mal kurz
zusammen
rein es gibt keine dem Taurus
Marschflugkörper
ähnlichen Flug Marschflugkörper die von
anderen geliefert worden sind weder die
amerikanische Cam mit einer Reichweite
von5 km noch stormshadow noch das
französische Modell haben eine auch nur
annäherend vergleichbare Reichweite wie
die Taurus zum zweiten hat es mir
gegenüber in der Ukraine keine
offizielle Anfrage nach Taurus Lieferung
gegeben in dem Gespräch was ich geführt
habe weil die Kollegen auf der
ukrainischen Seite wissen dass die
Position der Ukraine der Position der
Bundesregierung nach wie vor die ist die
ich ihn geschildert habe es gibt keinen
neuen Sachstand kleine Korrektur die
Antwort hat er gegeben bei der
regierungsbefragung war keine
Journalistenfrage aber wir haben es
gerade hört also Pistorius sagte wir
wärden die ersten und einzigen die
Waffen mit so einer Reichweite liefern
und er sagte vor allem auch es gäbe
keine offizielle Anfrage der Ukraine
nach Taurus wieso sind sie dann der
Meinung dass also Taurus dort so
dringend gebraucht würde das ist ja
nicht richtig was gerade berichtet wurde
er ist nicht gefragt worden aber es gibt
offizielle Anfragen an das
Bundeskanzleramt Taurus zu liefern und
die wurden abschlägig beschieden warum
soll sich ein Verteidigungsminister in
der Ukraine oder ein selenski eine
Abfuhr holen wenn er weiß dass der
Bundes des kanzleris ablehnt und er hat
ja auch gesagt offiziell wurde nicht
darüber gesprochen wir wissen alle dass
inoffiziell natürlich informell über
solche Fragen gesprochen wird und ich
weiß auch dass der Verteidigungsminister
ein sehr großer Befürworter einer
solcher lief solchen Lieferung wäre aber
das Kanzler möchte es nicht und er hat
ja auch herausgestellt warum dieses
System hat eine Reichweite die ein
bisschen also bisschen weniger als
doppelt sooweit ist wie die Verwandten
Storm Shadow und Skyp die haben alle
dieselbe Firma die die herstellt und
diese hat diese drei Typen ausgeliefert
die Bundesrepublik bestand darauf
Reichweiten mit etwa 500 km zu bekommen
weil wir keine eigene Luftüberlegenheit
haben Franzosen und Briten haben
stärkere Luftwaffen als wir und wir
haben deshalb abstandswaffen gewählt und
jetzt ist das Fatale dass die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland die als
einzige über so ein System außerhalb der
Amerikaner verfügen dieses System der
Ukraine verweigern und wir sehen den
Auges die russischen
versorgungslieferungen sehen und wir
werden die einzigen die da helfen können
und das ist ja das Bittere und ich spüre
aus den Worten des verteid
igungsministers auch eher die
Verbitterung dass wir das nicht liefern
können und wir haben es ein Ausweg wäre
es beispielsweise den Britten und
Franzosen zuur Verfügung zu stellen dass
sie es dann liefern oder den Amerikanern
oder dass die Produktion noch einmal
angeworfen wird aber das Entscheidende
ist dass wir unterlassene Hilfeleistung
erbringen und diesen Vorwurf muss sich
das Bundeskanzleramt wirklich gefallen
lassen weil hier das unnötig
Menschenleben kostet unnötig die Ukraine
um Dinge bettelt die selbstverständlich
sind nämlich alles zu tun und dann merkt
man eben auch dass der deutsche Spruch
aus dem Kanzleramt wir unterstützen die
Ukraine solange es nötig ist und wir
unterstützen sie in ihrer Verteidigung
nicht bedeutet dass es um die
Wiederherstellung der Grenzen von 91
geht und auch nicht bedeutet dass die
Ukraine gewinnen soll hier ist die
Regierung uneinig und wird durch die
Richtlinienkompetenz des Kanzlers
gelähmt würden sie dann soweit gehen
weil diese Frage habe ich hier gerade
von einem User Userin Oberberg gelesen
weil eben nicht F16 oder Tauris z.B
geliefert würden will die Nato nicht
dass Ukraine gewinnt und alles endlich
beendet wird und wenn ja warum nun das
Entscheidende ist ja dass wir uns über
die Kriegsziele einigen und das Lösen
nicht einzelne Waffensysteme sondern es
sind drei wesentliche Punkte erstens
dass die Versprechen die gemacht werden
auch eingehalten werden die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat sehr viel
versprochen aber die meisten Lieferungen
kommen erst Ende nächstes Jahr das ist
wahrscheinlich viel zu spät zweitens
dass die Ukraine eine Perspektive in EU
und NATO hat und das nicht argumentiert
wird wie man das aus Teilen der
deutschen Regierung hört dass eine
Einladung in die NATO eine Eskalation
für Putin Bedeut würde Putin eskaliert
ja die ganze Zeit gerade wo wir so wenig
liefern also die Perspektive NATO und EU
und das dritte ist dass sehr ehrlich
unsere Bevölkerung daruf auch aufmerksam
gemacht wird was der
Verteidigungsminister mit einem sehr
klugen Schachzug begonnen hat wir müssen
unsere Bevölkerung ehrlich aufklären
wenn die Ukraine fällt kommen 10 bis 15
Millionen weitere Menschen nach Europa
nach Mitteleuropa sie verlassen das
osteuropäische Land und davon werden 3
bis 4 Millionen nach Deutschland kommen
das ist viel teurer wir haben ja über
die Zahlen gesprochen 60% Sozialleistung
in der deutschen Unterstützung der
Ukraine viel teurer als jetzt mit einem
erheblichen militärischen Aufwand die
Ukraine zu befehgen dass sie wenigstens
nicht die Fehler wiederholen muss die
wir sie ins letzte Jahr gebracht haben
und in diesem Jahr zu wenig Munition zu
wenig Kampfpanzer zu wenig
Schützenpanzer und Artillerie sie
braucht deutlich mehr das hat saluschni
deutlich gemacht und auch kolleba aber
diese drei Punkte sind zu erfüllen die
klare Perspektive alle Waffen die nötig
sind und vor allen Dingen die
Vorbereitung unserer Bevölkerung dass
wir nicht aus der West asche und
nebenbei im Sommerurlaub so einen Krieg
aushalten werden das Lieferungen zu spät
kam das haben wir auch schon mal erlebt
schauen wir mal gemeinsam auf einen
Zeitraffer des Frontverlaufs seit Beginn
des russischen Angriff angriffskriegs
hier kann man jetzt sehen wie quasi
zunächst russische Truppen in orange
hier gekennzeichnet auf dem Vormarsch
waren zurückgedrängt worden sind und man
sieht also da ist viel Bewegung drin am
Anfang natürlich ganz viel und da jetzt
besonders erst im Osten und im Süden und
dann stagniert es jetzt das haben wir
auch gesehen also am Anfang ganz viel be
Bewegung dann eben immer weniger wir
haben es also auch am Anfang der Sendung
ja schon angesprochen größere Gebiet
gebietszurückgewinne sind Gelände
Gewinne sind gar nicht mehr gemacht
worden ist es denn überhaupt realistisch
mit jetzt auch all dem was Sie gesagt
haben was was man dafür bräuchte aber
ist es realistisch Russland in
absehbarer Zeit zurückdräen zu können
nun die Ukraine hat seit Kriegsbeginn
nachdem die großen Eroberungen Russlands
waren mehr als 50% des besetzten
Gebietes wieder befreit und das haben
sie mit der Unterstützung aus dem Westen
geleistet und wenn wir jetzt mehr tun
als nur wir unterstützen solange wie es
nötig ist sondern mit so viel wie
möglich so rasch wie möglich auch
unserer Bevölkerung deutlich machen dass
das eine Rückversicherung ist für uns
selbst dann hat die Ukraine jede Chance
diesen Krieg zu gewinnen und das sollten
wir auch deutlich machen und anerkennen
was die Ukraine hier bisher geleistet
hat wir sollten ihr auch Vertrauen und
wir müssen auch an einen Faktor denken
dass Hunderttausende männliche Ukrainer
im whrfähigen Alter ihr Land verlassen
haben hier gilt es auch zu appellieren
dass Sie mithelfen dass nicht die
Menschen an der Front verbluten sondern
dass sie entlastet werden das frisch
ausgebildetes Personal an der Front
unterstützt allein in Deutschland leben
über 200.000 whrfähige junge ukrainische
Männer oder Junge whrfähige zwischen 16
und 60 hier geht es also auch darum dass
wir mithelfen dass diese in ihr
Heimatland zurückkehren und dort
beispielsweise bei feuerwehrhelfen im
Katastrophenschutz sie müssen ja nicht
an die Front aber Sie müssen mithelfen
dass die ukrainische Gesellschaft das
ganze übersteht wir können es nicht aus
der Westentasche leisten und wir müssen
auch deutlich machen das ist mit einer
bestimmten Haltung zu verbinden nämlich
der whrfähigkeit und whrhaftigkeit ich
komme gerade aus USA und aus Kanada wo
mir sehr deutlich klar gemacht wurde die
Amerikaner wollen mehr tun sie erwarten
aber mehr Entlastung der Europäer es ist
ein Krieg auf europäischenem Boden und
die Amerikaner werden nach wie vor
unterstützen wenn Sie Ihre Grenzfrage im
Süden also eine Mauer nach Mexiko gelöst
haben aber es geht darum auch Trump zu
verhindern und wir haben es in der Hand
und es wäre furchtbar wenn in einem Jahr
nach den US-Wahlen gesagt würde Trump
sagt das ist ein europäischer Krieg ihr
habt nur ein Drittel von dem geleistet
was die Amerikaner geleistet haben ich
entziehe euch die Unterstützung und auch
den nuklearen Schutzschirm wir haben es
in der Hand auch unsere Sicherheit mit
einer starken Unterstützung der Ukraine
zu verbessern und glaubwürdige
transatlantische Lastenteilung ja
vorzuleben zum Schluss möchte ich gerne
noch eine Frage aus dem Stream an Sie
stellen sie kommt von Oliver Sassendorf
und er fragt sich früher oder später
wird es zu Verhandlungen kommen warum
denn nicht schon jetzt oder braucht der
Westen noch ein paar 100 Hektar mehr um
in eine bessere Verhandlungsposition in
um in einer besseren
Verhandlungsposition zu sein dieser User
glaubt also an die Verhandlung was
würden sie dem Antworten der Herr
Sassendorf berührt ja ein Punkt der die
deutsche Bevölkerung im weiten Maße
betrifft weil auch zu wenig erklärt wird
die Ukraine wollte immer und immer
wieder verhandeln und Russland hat
deutlich gemacht dass sie die ganze
Ukraine wollen und ja auch auf dem Weg
dorthin waren Putin möchte nicht
verhandeln weil er nicht verhandeln
braucht es geht ihm einfach darum Terror
Angst und Schrecken zu verbreiten und
vor allen Dingen zu zeigen dass er in
einer win-winsituation ist wenn die
Ukraine fällt gehen Millionen von
Menschen raus dann werden die
Europawahlen zu einem echten Problem
werden innenpolitisch und Verhandlungen
dazu gehören zwei über was soll denn die
Ukraine verhandeln über die Rückgabe von
20.000 entführten Kindern die mit neuem
Geburtsdatum und neuem Namen zur
Adoption freigegeben wurden über
tausende vergewaltigte Frauen über
hunderte kastrierte Männer über
ermordete Schulklassen über ermordete
Schwangere über was sollen sie
verhandeln und vor allen welche
Sicherheitsgarantien bekommen Sie dass
Russland nicht weiter angreift deshalb
da Russland seine Kriegsziele nicht
aufgegeben hat muss die Botschaft ganz
klar lauten die Ukraine verhandelt wenn
sie ihr Gebiet befreit hat und es geht
darum dass es Sicherheitsgarantien gibt
dass Russland das Existenzrecht all
seiner Nachbarstaaten anerkennt das
müssen die Verhandlungspunkte sein und
der Abzug der russischen Nuklearwaffen
aus Kaliningrad die unsere
Friedensbewegung überhaupt nicht stört
die russischen Truppen ins Transnistrien
und Georgien wir müssen das große Paket
schnüren weil Russland uns sonst in
einen großen Krieg einwickelt sagt CDU
Außenpolitiker Roderich Kiesewetter er
sagt wir haben es in der Hand vielen
Dank dass Sie bei uns zu Gast waren
vielen Dank für die Einladung danke
schön und ich habe noch einen Kommentar
von euch gelesen natürlich das Thema
treibt auch euch um diese unruhigen
Zeiten der letzte Kommentar kommt hier
von einem User Userin Manny Slider wir
müssen auch unabhängig von den nächsten
Entwicklungen in der Ukraine die Rüstung
hochfahren schreibt er da die Zeiten der
guten und friedlichen Nachbarschaft mit
Russland auf Sicht vorbei sind
wir werden auch morgen uns wieder der
Situation in der Ukraine widmen werden
euch da unser wöchentliches
militärupdate geben schaltet gerne ein
oder klickt rein und stellt vor allem
viele Fragen ich würde mich freuen und
deswegen wir sehen uns morgen sage ich
mal
tschüss